- Need a ride, girl?
It's bigger on the inside.
(energetic music)
- Do you play Quidditch?
Cause you look like a keeper.
- Will you force my star on?
Cause baby, you are precious.
- Are you a carbon sample?
Cause I wanna date you.
- Pardon my tangent, but what's your sign?
- Let's go to the bedroom.
I'll show you why they
call me the dungeon master.
- Girl, you must be the human torch
because you are on fire.
- Are you wifi, cause I feel a connection.
- Do you wanna know what
I keep in my utility belt?
- My name is Windows,
can I crash at your place?
- Do you have 11 protons?
Cause you are sodium fine.
- That's no moon.
- Mind if I slither in to
your chamber of secrets?
- Girl, I could spend a
millennium in your falcon.
- If I were an enzyme, I'd be DNA helicase
so I could unzip your gene.
- You know what a velociraptor sounds like
when it's in heat?
Aaarrrraaaggghhhh.
- Do you have a girlfriend?
I volunteer as tribute.
- Five, eight, zero, zero, eight
upside down.
- Let's get it on like Donkey Kong.
- Sit phasers, just stunning.
- Girl, gurl, okay, I'll go.